Speaker 1: , OK.
Senate Democrats are to propose federal cannabis
decriminalization.
For many people, one of the top issues of
the Joe Biden campaign was the full decriminalization
of cannabis, of marijuana at the federal level
as a starting point for hopefully eventual
rescheduling, further legalization.
Remember, decriminalization and legalization
are two different things, and we'll talk about
the impact of that actually on tomorrow's
program.
So it's not legalization that we're talking
about, but it is still a really, really big
deal.
CNBC reporting Senate Majority Leader Chuck
Schumer proposed legislation to legalize marijuana
at the federal level.
The Cannabis Administration and Opportunity
Act would remove marijuana from the Controlled
Substances Act and introduce regulations to
tax cannabis products.
Now, even the article is not exactly right
because the proposal is for decriminalize,
which is in the headline.
But then the point says Legalize.
That's not actually what the proposal is.
It would also expunge federal records of nonviolent
cannabis offenders.
This is a huge deal.
This was proposed yesterday.
And the idea here is start laying the groundwork
to ease legislation that while it may not
in the way that it is written, disproportionately
target poor people and people of color in
practice.
That's what the war on drugs has done.
And we know because we've heard from the people
who were involved in the creation of the current
infrastructure we have around the criminality
of drugs, that that was actually the goal.
The war on drugs was a I mean, I sort of want
to say racially tinged, but that's not really
strong enough.
It was a racially targeted reaction to the
civil rights movement that started in the
late 50s and sort of made more progress during
the 1960s in the United States.
The proposal, the Cannabis Administration
and Opportunity Act would remove marijuana
from the Controlled Substances Act and introduce
regulations to cannabis products.
The proposal would expunge federal records
of nonviolent cannabis offenders and allow
people serving time in federal prison and
importantly, federal, not state, for nonviolent
marijuana crimes to petition a court for resentencing.
The plan would also create an opportunity
trust fund from new cannabis tax revenue in
order to invest in programs for communities
most affected by the, quote, failed war on
drugs, according to a draft of the bill.
Now, what what is the probability of this
becoming law?
The plan to decriminalize marijuana will likely
face a contentious battle in the Senate, as
it's generally opposed by Republicans and
some moderate Democrats and has not received
an endorsement from President Joe Biden.
Schumer will require 60 votes, including at
least 10 GOP votes, to pass it through the
Senate in terms of what we've seen on legalization
and.
Criminalization so far, so far, 37 states
and D.C. have legalized medical cannabis in
the 18 states and D.C. have legalized recreational
use, but it is still illegal under federal
law.
Public polling shows that nearly 70 percent
of Americans support legalizing the drug.
So there's a bunch of stories here.
One story is, is Joe Biden going to, after
what he talked about during his campaign,
come out and endorse this particular bill?
As many of you know, in politics, often you
campaign on supporting an idea and then when
a bill is put forth, that would make that
idea a reality.
Oftentimes, politicians will say, well, this
particular bill, as written, has this problem,
has that problem and remains to be seen whether
where Joe Biden is going to land on this particular
bill.
Number two, we have talked increasingly over
the years about how in the United States the
policy desires of the American people as a
whole often don't get made a reality.
And this is this is for a number of different
reasons.
One reason is that our elected officials are
far more conservative than the population
at large.
If you look at sort of the average political
placement on the spectrum of at the federal
level, senators and members of Congress, and
you compare their their positions on policy
to those of the American people.
For example, 70 percent support legalization.
And yet we don't even know that we can get
60 percent of the Senate to say, yeah, I'll
vote for this bill.
That's one issue that we've talked about as
well.
So there's a number of different stories here.
And we know that corporations and elites and
the wealthy have outsized influence on what
actually becomes law and what the legislative
priorities are relative to just the average
person.
One stunning example of this is, of course,
after the Sandy Hook school shooting during
Barack Obama's presidency, which was now many
I don't even know the number of years.
It's way more it feels way more recent than
than it actually is.
There was like eighty eight, 90 percent support
for what's called universal background checks
among the American people in the United States.
And yet Democrats who at the time controlled
the White House, the House and the Senate
were not able to get universal background
checks made into law.
And there's a ton of different reasons for
why that is, and all of them corrosive to
the idea of a representative democracy.
But that's one example, the American people's
view now on cannabis, at minimum, decriminalization
is another example.
Here's an opportunity good for Chuck Schumer
for putting forth the bill, but we will see
where it actually goes on August 16th.
It is the 16th.
Speaking of it feels like yesterday it is
the 16th anniversary of The David Pakman Show.
And we will be doing a one day huge membership
special 16.
It's going to be related to the number 16
because it is the 16th anniversary of the
show.
That's on Monday, August 16th.
If you would like to be notified of this historic,
it's an historic and a historic opportunity
to sign up for a membership.
Just get on my newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
And then Monday morning, that's Monday, August
16th, you'll get an email telling you how
to sign up.
Let's take a quick break.
What a packed show we have for you today.
Remember that our show does depend in a real
way on folks like you who sign up for memberships
on our website and we do produce an extra
entire show for our members.
You can sign up at join Pakman dot com and
use the coupon code better.
Twenty one to get a discount if you so please.
The the normal prices are very, very good,
but I am glad to offer an even bigger discount
with the code better.
Twenty one which you can use at joint Pakman
dot com